which presentation the publisher
revealed our first solid look at what
games will be arriving on the platform
hold onto your hats because Mario is
getting ready to throw his in Super
Mario Odyssey the new 3d Mario game
features a mildly creepy version of
Mario's hat which features eyes and
looks to be a pretty big part of the
game Nintendo showed off a city location
Bowser in peach drama and Mario using
his hat as a platform to jump off of the
game will feature a large sandbox world
and areas located outside of the
Mushroom Kingdom
it's two out in the holiday season of
2017 producer Hisashi Nogami popped out
on stage with jewel paint guns to
announce splatoon - which will include
new weapons battle stages and encourage
players to explore new strategies the
game can be controlled with either the
joy controllers or the pro controller
and will have post to launch DLC and
events much like the first game Nintendo
also announced party game 1 to switch
which will arrive alongside the console
on March 3 1 2 switch features face to
face games where you'll employ the
detached joique on controllers including
a time-based
duel game as well as games that feature
sword fighting or wizard jewels and a
guitar Nintendo also revealed a fighting
sports game called arms which you play
with a joy cone controller in each hand
that you use to physically throw punches
across the ring with motion controls
arms lets you fight an opponent locally
in a split-screen mode or online and
will arrive in spring of this year
monolith soft showed off the next game
in the action role-playing Xenoblade
series with a very pretty trailer
Xenoblade Chronicles 2 was debuted
alongside a new Fire Emblem game which
will adopt a dynasty warrior style
Atlas announced the next mainland shin
megami tensei game but as dishonored
confirmed the Skyrim will be coming to
switch and EA later added that they're
bringing FIFA to the console during the
presentation Nintendo announced over 80
games are in development for the switch
and roll the montage of what's on the
way you ready everything yet to mention
minecraft story mode super Bomberman
state Mario Kart 8 deluxe Rayman snip
Eclipse has been heroes lego city
undercover Dragon Ball xenoverse two
farming simulator Just Dance 2017
Skylanders imagine ators Ultra Street
Fighter 2 minecraft Rhyme fast racing
neo NBA 2k 18 Dragon Quest Heroes 1 and
2 Dragon Quest 10 and 11 of projects up
to path traveller and suda51 made an
appearance to announce that No More
Heroes
or at least a game featuring Travis
touchdown will also be coming to switch
nin tones were capped off their
presentation by showing off brand new
gameplay from The Legend of Zelda breath
of the wild link is depicted taking on
gargantuan beasts gliding through the
air and discovering more about his
history and quest breath of the wild
will be arriving alongside the switch at
launch on March 3 and will also be
available on Wii U on the same date for
everything switch and all the other
things going on in gaming don't switch
away from games but